go to Fox's Wikipedia  and you see go to his wife  get to the right who is married to okay  zoom in a little bit so we can see it  Christy Grady right okay so who is  Christy Grady go to Christine Grady  watch this zoom in Christine Grady is an  American and bioethics  who serves as the head of the Department  of bioethics at the National Institute  of Health clinical Center NIH  i h wow that's so her job is to hold him  accountable what did you did you did you  just  okay so the basically the the the HR of  your job is your wife  there's no country there's no conflict  of interest there no way are you are you  kidding me can you like not real that's  that can't be real no no that's real  that Israel